Coburn Nicki independent 842 Haman sue
Labour Party 16,000 312 huge Neil
Liberal Democrat 1525 ivanson Roy Allen
87 Jenkinson mark the Conservative Party
20,000
[Applause]
[Music]
20,000 488 Perry Jill green party 596
Walker David brexit party 1749 well
there we have it working turn tumbling
as anybody our man on the spot they was
telling us working to man was one of the
phrases going for this election a
conservative game from labor they did
have a majority the Labour Party did
have a majority of 4000 that's been
almost identically reversed by Mark
Jenkins putting the Conservatives in
there with a majority four thousand one
hundred and seventy-six sue Heyman
shadow cabinet member ejected from
Parliament's and her vote chair let's
take you through them her vote chair
fell quite considerably as you know by
at least 4000 share 39% there this
change in chair is perhaps the most
interesting of the evening as the
Conservatives start picking up these
seats that Labour used to be incredibly
strong it up seven and a half percent
baby back down in eleven point nine
percent the brexit party a performance
their four point two percent some cuts
are deputy political editor is putting
all these into his database and reading
what it tells us and what it tells us
some even from down here is is that this
exit poll is looking pretty accurate
absolutely Dermot that's increasingly
clear we are on course for a majority
around the range of the 86 that we saw
in the exit poll at 10 o'clock just look
at the swing in that seat of Workington
Workington has been labor since 1979 now
there's been a swing from the Labour
Party to the Conservatives in the region
of 10 percent so if you look the Tories
now have around 50 percent of the vote
in that seat and that was that that was
what the Labour Party got in the 2017
election so now there's a
whopping 4,000 majority in this what was
once an absolute labor heartland so I
think that will be perhaps the result
this evening that has stung the Labour
Party the most if we want to look at one
other result um in Lavery the Labour
Party Chairman there were rumors that he
might even lose his seat he has hung on
but by only the slimmest of margins we
had that result in the last few minutes
and there his majority has gone down
from 10,000 at this election to 814
again swing in the region of about seven
eight percent from Labour to the
Conservatives in Lavery will be glad to
have hung on but that kind of decline in
his support in his in his seat will
sting whether it means he doesn't run
for the debt to leadership or not will
remain to be seen
okay we're just looking at that result
in fault Sam thank you very much indeed
for the analysis and back there to
working to understand was saying there
I'm getting there first Conservative MP
for 40 years there the shadow
Environment Secretary sue Heyman losing
a sea